[Musique]
saint petersbourg un vendredi soir de
pamiers mais les rues sont désertes
tous les bars et restaurants fermés mais
ne vous laissez pas tromper par les
apparences car il suffit de savoir où
aller d'être discret un code secret un
texto et le tour est joué pour pénétrer
dans le night live clandestin d'une
bulle confie si pour iegor c'est une
façon de proclamer sa liberté pour le
propriétaire du bar dany lipovetsky
c'est une question survie pour
l'histoire sont baissées l'éclairage
tamisé
il peut compter sur un réseau d'amis
biais branchies qu'il prévienne quand la
police a fait l'effet d'un lot d'espoirs
car il ya de la compétition beaucoup
ils sont des centaines d'entrepreneurs
indépendants qui ont décidé de violer
les règles de confinement parmi les plus
sévères au monde
c'est fischer un autre tenanciers à
éviter notre équipe dans son bar de jazz
secrets le temps de boire un verre et de
partager ses frustrations
il y en a beaucoup ils opèrent sur
invitation seulement
on se croirait dans les années 20 à
l'époque de la prohibition
d'où le gouvernement et les banques se
moque carrément mois alors moi je me
moque de leur loi c'est aussi simple que
ça dit alex et qui a rouvert son studio
box illégalement ça fait des semaines
qu'il attend qu'elle d'urgence promis
par l'état mais en vain la bureaucratie
et internet
j'ai deux filles à nourrir mais on
s'attend à ce que je fasse quoi juste
pour gagner ma vie ici pas de masque de
distance de toute façon la connaît jy
crois pas dimitri il n'y a rien comme la
boxe pour se refaire une santé physique
et mentale
ils sont devenus de bouche à oreille les
moteurs d'une économie souterraine que
la police semble tolérer ou est
incapable de stopper et l'enad qu'elle
n'est pas du genre belle mais elle s'est
laissée tenter par une coupe de cheveux
en cachait sa coiffeuse l'ena et privés
de revenus
si tu as pas d'âme l'industrie de la
beauté dit elle n'a reçu aucun soutien
pas un sou vous feriez quoi si vous
étiez à ma place le taux de chômage a
déjà plus que doublé en russie et le
tiers des compagnies privées risque la
faillite
et tant qu'il y aura des clients on sera
là pour leur changer les idées dit
rawdon le barman c'est gagnant gagnant
sa droite
instinct de survie tout simple
désinvolture
[Musique]
loin des regards la vie continue dans
les grandes villes de russie
[Musique]